we have so far spent many videos talking
about the ideal
gas law that pressure times volume is
equal to the number of moles times the
ideal gas constant times temperature
measured in kelvin what we're going to
do in this video is attempt to
modify the ideal gas law to try to take
into account
when we're dealing with real gases gas
is where
the volume of the actual particles are
worth considering that we don't just say
they're negligible compared to the
volume of the container
and intermolecular forces are something
that we would like to take into
consideration
so let's think about how we could modify
this and to help us a little bit
i'm just going to solve for p so i'm
going to divide both sides by volume
so we can say pressure is equal to
number of moles times ideal gas constant
times temperature measured in kelvin
divided by volume so first how would we
adjust this
if we want to take into account the
actual volume
in which the molecules can move around
well if we wanted to do that we would
replace this volume
right over here with this volume minus
the volume of the actual
particles so what's the volume of the
actual particles going to be
well it's going to be the number of
particles
times some constant based on how large
each of those particles are maybe on
average
and let's just call that b
so we could view this as a modified
ideal
gas law equation where now all of a
sudden we are
taking into account the fact that these
particles have some real volume to them
but of course we also know it's not just
about the volume of the particles
we also need to adjust for the
intermolecular forces between the
particles
and we know that in many cases those
intermolecular forces are attractive
forces
and so they would take away from the
pressure and so we need some term that
accounts for that a term that
accounts for taking away the pressure
due to intermolecular forces
so term for
intermolecular inter molecular
forces now i know what some of y'all are
thinking
do we always subtract might not there be
some situations in which
we actually have repulsive forces
between particles and it would actually
add to the pressure
and there could be scenarios like that
you could imagine if they all have a
strong negative charge they want to get
away from each other as far as they can
and that could actually
add to the pressure but in that
situation we could subtract a negative
and then that would be
additive now how can we take this into
consideration
so we know from coulomb's law that the
force between
two particles two charged particles is
going to be proportional to
the charge on one particle times the
charge on the other particle
divided by the distance squared now
obviously if we're dealing with
a lot of particles in a container we're
not going to be able to think about the
forces for
between any two particles but one way to
think about it is in terms of how
concentrated are the particles generally
so we're trying to think of a term that
takes into account the intermolecular
forces or how much we're reducing the
pressure because of those intermolecular
forces
maybe that can be proportional to not
just the concentration
of the particles and that would be the
number of particles divided by the
volume
but that times itself because we're
talking about the interaction between
two particles at a time very similar to
what we see in coulomb's law because the
end of
these really are just coulomb forces so
this thing right over here is going to
be
proportional to the concentration times
itself
or we could maybe call this some
constant
for the proportionality times n
over v squared where a would depend on
the attractive forces
between gas particles and what we have
just constructed and let me rewrite it
again
this ideal gas equation and actually let
me put this orange term
back on the left hand side so if i write
it this way that pressure
plus a
times n over v
squared is equal to
n rt over
the volume of our container minus the
number of molecules we have
times some constant b based on how large
on average those
molecules or those particles are this
right over here
is a pretty good compensating equation
for when we're dealing with more
real gases ones that have intermolecular
forces and one where the actual
particles have
volume and this actually does a pretty
good job
and there's a name for it it's called
the van der waals
equation and there's many different ways
you might see it you could see it
written like this
or we could try to take this blue part
and get it on the left hand side so it
really looks like what we saw at the top
where there it would be written as and
i'll write it actually write it this way
pressure plus some
constant times the density squared
let me close that parenthesis times
the volume minus some the number of
molecules times some
constant is going to be equal to nrt
is going to be equal to n rt and all of
this looks really complicated but the
end of the day it is just our ideal
gas law modified for intermolecular
forces
and the actual volume of the particles